[Musique]
on appelle les travailleurs les chômeurs
les retraités du monde du travail à à
voter pour la liste lutte ouvrière pour
faire entendre le camp des travailleurs
face à la grande bourgeoisie face au
grand capital
cette grande bourgeoisie ultra
milliardaire s'accapare toutes les
richesses de la société se comporte
comme un rouleau compresseur
sur l'ensemble de la société vit un
train de vie de luxe avec la peau des
travailleurs il faut que dans ces
élections les travailleurs fassent
entendre leur intérêt leur intérêt de
travailleurs et met en avant des
objectifs de lutte pour défendre leurs
conditions de vie l'europe à protéger
les travailleurs
l'europe elle protège les capitalistes
elle protège les milliardaires
elles protègent les riches les seuls qui
pourront protéger les travailleurs c'est
les travailleurs eux mêmes par leur
lutte par leur mobilisation par la force
social qu'il représente
quand ils se mettent en bagarre quand
ils se mettent en grève on milite pour
que les travailleurs prennent en main
leur destin et défendre leurs intérêts
par la lutte le changement ne viendra
que par le bas jamais par le haut
[Musique]
c'est un faux débat
c'est même plus qu'un faux débat c'est
un piège qui est étendue à la fois par
ceux de macron qui pensent que l'europe
et fraternelle et solidaire ça c'est un
mensonge tout comme les le pen ou les
houles et où les mélenchon qui sont anti
européen les travailleurs doivent se
faire entendre en tant que travailleur
si la france devait quitter l'europe
c'est les travailleurs qui devrait payer
la note
si la france doit rester en europe c'est
les travailleurs qui paient la note
ben nous on veut que ça soit les
milliardaires on veut que ça soit la
grande bourgeoisie qui paye la note
on en a marre nous les travailleurs les
chômeurs les retraités de payer pour les
riches
[Musique]